hey what's going on it's bill burr
and it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and i'm
[Music]
just checking in on
you hey
what's up man you know if you're if
you're a uh a normal
listener what is normal i don't need
somebody shut the [ __ ] up sorry
i got those [ __ ] people's voices in
my head now what is
who are you here
um if you're a normal
listener a regular listener of this
podcast
on monday or on on sunday i told you
that i i i i done told you that i was
recording the podcast
because because because because because
i was getting my second vaccine shot
wow i was getting my second vaccine shot
um of sufficer
yeah um and that was the one that i was
like man you take that thing i'm the
first one to find little showroom you
get that jack one you'll be
all [ __ ] up right so
i did the usual thing i'm like you know
what these [ __ ] people live [ __ ]
[ __ ]
they're probably exaggerating
you know you know people oh my god i'm
starving
oh my god oh my god i had the worst
day right you know there is an element
of that right
so anyway so i do the podcast because
you know i didn't want to be all [ __ ]
uh
billy clam cakes over here all [ __ ]
sweaty and [ __ ]
trying to do a [ __ ] podcast because i
respect
my audience all right i respect you
[ __ ] okay
so anyway sunday
treat turdy i go over to a cvs
and uh i [ __ ] go in there
the lady checks me and is cool as [ __ ]
she tells me to go stand in aisle 11 or
some [ __ ] so i stand there
and as always as always when you're
standing in line what comes
that [ __ ] person that acts like they
don't see the line they're standing to
the side
it was a chick right and she was
standing just to my side a little in
front of me didn't look down the aisle
just standing there
so i'm just sitting there you know
really been working on the temper as
always so i'm just like
if this [ __ ] thinks she's gonna get in
front of me uh it ain't happening so
what i did
was i just out passive aggressive her
like
she was one step in front of me i said
okay i see you're one step in front of
me and i one two put you [ __ ] behind
me
and she glanced over at me and i looked
right at her
all right and that was the old [ __ ]
emotional right there fred shut the [ __ ]
up
and so i went up checked in
was all good and then i i turned and i
looked at the person behind me and made
sure that they stepped up
but then the last person the third
person in line
was sort of a wishy-washy you know i
don't like confrontation
and that [ __ ] [ __ ] cut in front of
her
i should have said ma'am the line's back
here aisle 11
for this window stupid [ __ ]
and it was funny was then we lined up to
get the vaccine and i saw when she
walked over she saw the line and she was
like
you know so these [ __ ] doctors are
gonna save your [ __ ] life you stupid
[ __ ]
or or help you go back to work or
[ __ ] save your grandparent's life for
something you [ __ ] idiot right then
there was like three of us there
you sit down hey how's it going which
arm do you want it in
and it's over so they um give me the
second shot
and i'm like all right somebody told me
you know to get some tylenol take a
couple of tylenol a few hours later or
whatever you should be good so i got
that
i got some toothpaste for the family uh
what else did i get i don't know what
else i got and then i got in the car
and uh i was like all right here we go
what's gonna happen
how sick am i gonna get right and
you know seven it was like 3 30 by 7 30
8 o'clock that night
i still felt fine oh i bought some
gatorade so i was drinking gatorade
i took the two tylenols i was drinking
water
you know my piss was clear right i was
hydrated
and i [ __ ] you know i went to bed
i went to bed
and um still felt fine
and then i woke up at four in the
morning
i think out of nervousness to be like am
i sick yet
and i still felt fine right and i heard
it was if 12 to 17 hours
right so at that point it was four in
the morning i was like all right
okay so i'm a half hour into the zone
where i'm supposed to be getting sick
if i'm gonna get sick it's gonna be
right around the time
i gotta get the kids to school and all
of that [ __ ] and uh
that time rolled around and i was fine
and i was like oh [ __ ]
i didn't get sick i knew i was tougher
than these [ __ ] people
right then i talked to one of my buddies
and he goes oh yeah he goes i got i got
the fisa
he goes i got mine at 3 30 in the
afternoon too he goes right around
noon the next day i got sick and i was
like what the [ __ ]
that's past 17 hours
so i looked it up online and it said you
can have side effects anywhere from
24 to 48 hours later and i was like oh
what the [ __ ]
so when you know right around 11 i
started feeling a little weird
right didn't feel sick but i felt a
little weird i was like the [ __ ] going
on here
heads you know that feeling right before
you're going to get sick of oh no right
so i took another
couple time on two two the day before i
took two the next day
and i felt weird for about 90 minutes to
two hours
and then it just went away
and then i could kind of feel like all
right whatever the [ __ ] was gonna happen
i'm already on the other side of it i
kind of just knew
but i didn't want to talk too much [ __ ]
and uh that's all that happened
that's all that happened i didn't get
sick at all so um i'm also you know
i never had covid and i'm also sober as
a [ __ ] church mouse these days
like i'm not doing anything nothing then
my stupid milkshakes are malts on the
[ __ ] weekend i have one of those
and i'm eating pretty good and i was
getting plenty of sleep
so there you go so there's some good
news for you because all these [ __ ]
pieces of [ __ ] on the news all i do is
try to scare the [ __ ] out of you
but the dumb johnson and johnson think
seven million people
and then six people have a [ __ ]
problem and then i love all these
anti-vaxxers
anti-mass people flip out about six
[ __ ] people
when you know hundreds of thousand
people are dying of covert they're like
well more people die of the flu
so hundreds of thousands of people dying
to covet doesn't bother you but
six out of seven million does because
you don't want to take a [ __ ] vaccine
unbelievable unbelievable it's like
i think that doctors need to talk more
[ __ ]
they should have came out with from the
people that cured polio
comes the vaccine but the people who
stopped every
[ __ ] plague we've ever [ __ ] had
that's why we don't have plagues anymore
because of doctors
[ __ ] those guys listening to those guys
all right you know do whatever you want
to do
i know i did so anyways oh billy
freckles is uh here's the deal too
so i am not fully vaccinated until april
25th because it's 14 days
after you get your second shot because
there's a lot of people just getting one
you know it's the usual [ __ ] people i'm
telling you you want to be successful in
life
complete it cross the t's dot the eyes
do what the [ __ ] needs to be done
most people they start it they still
come on how many [ __ ]
old cars you see sitting at people's
yeah i'm gonna fix that up one day
they're never gonna do it they're never
gonna do it
i'm gonna clean this up i'm gonna
[ __ ] do this i'm gonna get one of
these
mo people run their yaps
some people actually start the process
but very few complete
those who complete have the highest
chance of being successful at whatever
the [ __ ] they want to do that is the end
of my little life lesson
all right let's talk the bruins the
boston boston bruins
uh made a little trade there we got uh
taylor hall
from the buffalo sabres interesting
interestingly enough i believe his first
game back
uh with the bruins i mean i should say
it was against the boston bruin i mean
the buffalo sabres
who we beat last night in overtime um
you know i thought the bruins looked
pretty good still like to see us score
more
uh did pretty good in the fights and
uh kind of love the brush man in a
shootout to brush the [ __ ] guy always
scores
lifts that leg does a little wiggle and
then i see you know [ __ ] top shelf
and the
goalie's like what the [ __ ] just
happened jolly coyle
had the other overtime um shootout goal
and uh it was a fun game i was kind of
in a writing
meeting zoom meeting and i just had the
game on in the background so i didn't
catch too much
of the uh you know i didn't
catch too much of the commentary or
anything but it was kind of funny like i
watched that
that hit that caused that fight where
miller you know
[ __ ] clocked that dude on the uh
sabres was a tough kid he popped right
back
up he also did a good job of not taking
the full shot
i felt but it was funny was you know
the hit was a little high and it did hit
him in the head it causes his head to
slam off the [ __ ] glass
and of course our homer announcers who i
love are just like uh
you know and the uh refs didn't have a
problem with it
what that means is if it happened to a
bruin they would have been flipping out
and i'm sure
the buffalo people like going a high hit
and so and so takes exception you know
we didn't you know he he
he showed up you know that that means a
lot that means a lot
miller's uh you know that's what he does
he's an enforcer and our our guy is
actually a goal scorer but he still had
the courage to drop the gloves you know
that they went that way on it
um so anyway uh
what else red sox have won like four in
a row we were playing the orioles who i
guess are just gonna suck this year
uh that actually made me feel bad i was
watching the game and one of the red sox
announcers was just like yeah they're
gonna have a long year
this is gonna be a long year for those
guys can you [ __ ] imagine that
i mean i know you're making a ton of
money and [ __ ] is a major league ball
player but i just can't imagine
you know even if you're not going to
make the playoffs you still have to play
162 games
oh and then you got to talk about it to
the sports reporters afterwards like
jesus christ
um anyway but i
i watched a little replay of that game
we won i think like
14 to nine some crazy like football
score
against the orioles and we beat the
twins i think last night so we should be
playing them tonight
and um was really
enjoying it seeing some fans come back
and stuff has been a nice thing
so uh yeah i like baseball i like them
all i like them all in motogp
this [ __ ] weekend the kink is coming
back
mark marquez who broke his uh humorous
beginning of last season came back the
next race and then
shut it down and uh he's had a couple of
setbacks with the
um i think they just want to make sure
he was like 100 like
sydney crosby level before he comes back
so
i'm looking forward to that race uh this
sunday
um nba fans who miss competition
you know watching these night of too
many stars teams that they seem to be
putting together
for the inevitable nba final of the
lakers against the [ __ ]
brooklyn nets um dark horse utah jazz
possibly
um i don't know in the east or whatever
i have no idea but um
yeah anyway if you'd like to see
competition if you missed that in your
sports i would watch uh
i would watch some of the moto gp this
weekend just saying just say
i actually had some time this week too i
uh
i sat down and played some drums and i
for my level for my skill set i'm just
talking about me i
[ __ ] crushed it my foot was as fast
as it's ever been
and uh i'll tell you a great thing to
keep your foot fast
if you want to just sort of keep those
that little that triplet thing that
bonham does
i play to uh black dog which is 84 bpms
and has that little triplet lick in
there a bunch of those thrown in
then i play to traveling riverside blues
which is 90 bpms
and then i play to uh
good times bad times and um my warm up
is poor tom
underrated zeppelin album as far as
drums and all that [ __ ] and fun stuff to
play
is the koda album um
there's a lot of fun just you know poor
tom
darlene uh traveling riverside blues
obviously they tacked that one on later
that wasn't on the
original release but there's there's a
number of really just like
you know i don't even if it's a
throwaway zeppelin track just to hear
what he did
on those albums because i i didn't
really listen to that album as much
as maybe i should have um
so anyways i [ __ ] crushed it and then
today i came down
sat down um after doing all of this
stuff in the morning i was rushing
around and promoting my tour
and was on calling uh cowherd i oh i
love that guy man i have such a [ __ ]
great time
whenever i'm on uh on his show
um i did rich eisens podcast just a
bunch of really great guys
and um i don't know what i didn't really
stretch or anything like that i just
kind of went out there stretched
did some half-assed stretch and i got
behind the kit and i just sucked and i
was like
[ __ ] i thought the guy yesterday was the
guy i was
um and then the reality sets in is not
you're somewhere
between that guy and the [ __ ] that's
coming out of you today
so that's always fun right
let's talk about setbacks everybody huh
[ __ ] sit there thinking you're making
progress and whatnot
then all of a sudden you're not you know
um
it bums me out but like i i i tell you i
i got that book
um the benny greb book on on
effective practicing and i get really
good prac like 20
solid [ __ ] minutes of practice before
i just [ __ ] around and play songs
and uh it's definitely showing uh
the results so anyway sorry if i'm a
little scatterbrained here today
everybody i've been uh
i kind of been all over the place but um
i've been doing a good job though
as far as like working on myself i'm
psyched like this this morning
uh i would have had an epic fight with
my wife and i didn't
and then four [ __ ] things happened in
a row
and i didn't react to any of them and i
kept my cool
and everybody had a nice morning like um
my wife's been busting her ass lately
working on this project and uh
i guess she was really tired and she was
sleeping next to me
and you know she was [ __ ] you know
snoring a little bit and just woke me up
and once i wake up
forget it i'm just up so i was like [ __ ]
so i
i went downstairs and i slept on the
couch
and uh you know i wake go upstairs the
next morning she's like hey
sorry did i wake you up and i was like
yeah
and uh i don't know and then she's just
like oh sorry and then immediately she
was looking at her phone
and i'm thinking like oh my god that's
all i get is sorry
i missed out on two hours sleep if you
literally get up
eight minutes before you usually get up
you're gonna be in a grumpy mood all
morning you go right to your phone like
that normally would have
got me i would have [ __ ] had that
dumb fight
you know because for all i know she's
texting my daughter's school about some
[ __ ] i didn't i
would have normally jumped right in i
just
i walked out i was like what the [ __ ]
and then i was just as i was going down
the stairs i was like no
i'm not doing this and i was like all
right well you know what i have that
radio tour tomorrow morning i'm calling
a bunch of radio sir
um shows early starting with some radio
station in st
louis i'm just like i'm just gonna sleep
in my office tonight
there okay that's the solution okay
problem solved i felt good then i wasn't
upset with that
then i go downstairs and i [ __ ] you
know i'm gonna
you know my daughter wants some uh these
healthy pancakes that i make so i say
okay
i go to the spice rack where's the
sentiment why are all the why are all
the spices [ __ ] not alphabetized
what the [ __ ] and i can't find it and i
didn't lose my cool
then i was looking for the little
measuring cup it wasn't where it's
supposed to be i look at the dishwasher
it's not there it's not in the sink it's
not in the dry rack
i look back in the drawer and there it
is didn't lose my cool
then the [ __ ] scooper where the [ __ ]
is everything that i needed was not
where the [ __ ] it normally is for
whatever [ __ ] reason and all of those
little things
i i the old me would have been like how
[ __ ] hard is it to put the [ __ ]
spice back
alphabetically so the next person
doesn't have to [ __ ] charge it no i
would have done that
i would have done that and i didn't
i just went like well it's got to be
here somewhere and uh you know i have
plenty of time to make these [ __ ]
pancakes
i re-alphabetized everything knowing
full well that i'm the only one that
gives a [ __ ]
about it being alphabetized
i just plowed through all of that
everybody had a great time and guess
what
it's like [ __ ] eight hours later and
who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] and i figured out why
i'm an angry guy
in therapy i get it now
i get me and um
yeah it feels pretty [ __ ] good man
i'm telling you you only need to do
mushrooms once
and you really figure yourself out if
you do the [ __ ] work
if you do the work so yeah all of that
shit's good man
it's all [ __ ] good so um but having
said that i'm saying some of the most
ignorant [ __ ] i've ever said in my life
on stage i have
like three bits i cannot wait to [ __ ]
try out
and you know just knowing the how people
are
or certain people nowadays it's gonna be
a lot of fun
so while i still have advertisers on
this podcast let's uh let's read some
here
all right movement watches everybody
mvn mike victor mike
tango um in a tiny apartment
in southern california two college
dropouts teamed up to create a watch
company
that broke all the rules
with fair prices unexpected colors and
clean original designs
mvmt pronounced movement grew
into one of the fastest growing watch
brands shipping to over 160 countries
across the
globe globe globe globe now mvmt has
expanded into blue light glasses that
protect your eyes
from your screens minimalist jewelry and
more style
essentials that don't break the bank all
designed out of their
california headquarters um
movement watchers have the look and
quality of a 400
to 500 watch you're paying for at a
department store but
cost a fraction of the price because
they were built online
and their process went oh what they were
built online and own their process from
start to finish so they can keep the
cost
down um you get a beautiful watch
ship right to your door for free and if
you don't love it you can ship it right
back for free
um let's see here i've got
i've got to spend all day in front of my
computer and my ever scroll blue light
filtering glasses are a game changer i i
never got him i want those things so
[ __ ] bad uh it really helps with eye
strain and poor
this is me in the future saying this and
poor sleeping patterns and i love the
modern style of the frames i'm texting
andrew right now for one of these
[ __ ] things
um if you want to elevate your look with
style that doesn't break the bank then
join the movement and get 15 off today
with free
shipping and free returns by going to
movement.com
that's mvmt
again that's michael victor
michaeltango.com
all right oh look who it is everybody
it's [ __ ] headspace man
wouldn't be great if they were a
pocket-sized guide that helped you
sleep slash focus slash act
slash be better question mark
well there is and if you have 10 minutes
headspace can change
your life next please mention all the
talking points below
you know i believe i was meditating
today when i couldn't find the
[ __ ] cinnamon uh headspace is your
daily dose of mindfulness in the form of
guided meditations in an easy to use app
headspace is one of the only meditation
apps advancing the field of mindfulness
and meditation through clinically
validated research
so whenever the situation whatever the
situation
headspace really can help you feel
better overwhelmed headspace has a
three-minute
sos meditation for you jesus i need one
of those
uh needs some help falling asleep yes
headspace has a wind-down
session their members swear by and for
parents
headspace even has morning meditations
you can go do with your kids
headspaces approach to mindfulness can
reduce stress
improve sleep boost focus and increase
your overall sense of well-being
headspace is backed by 25 published
studies on its benefits
six hundred thousand five star reviews
and headspace makes it easy for you to
build a life-changing meditation
practice
with mindfulness that works for you on
your schedule anytime anywhere
you deserve to feel happier and
headspace is meditation made simple
go to headspace.com bird that's
headspace.com for free
for a free one month trial with access
to headspaces full library of
meditations for every situation
this is the best deal offered right now
head to
headspace.com today and lastly
but certainly not leastly um
helix helix has this quiz that takes
just two minutes to complete
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect
mattress for you uh
why would you buy a mattress made for
someone else i don't know
low self-esteem um with
because i don't think i'm special all
right with helix
you're getting a mattress that you know
will be perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so they have several different mattress
models to choose from they have soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot or even a helix plus
mattress
for plus size sleepers it's awesome
getting unboxing videos from so many of
you
who also who also found the helix
mattress of your dreams
so if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress
that you're matched to
and the mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free you don't ever
need to go to a mattress store again
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
and by gq and wired magazine
i don't think there needs to be an end
there was voted awarded number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020
by gq and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com
take the two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life they have a 10-year warranty
and you get to try it out for a hundred
nice risk-free
uh they'll even pick it up gross if you
don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders
and just two and two free pillows uh for
our listeners at helixsleep.com
h-e-l-i-x-s-l-e-e-p
dot com slash burr b-u-r-r
um why did i think you didn't know how
to spell sleep what are you trying to
insult us there billy boy there billy
freckles
um oh [ __ ] you know i really wanted to
talk about this [ __ ] thing
with my wife um we watch those true
crime things when we go to bed i don't
know she's into the [ __ ] and i just
i've given in i watch the real
housewives of atlanta now
um i can handle it now cause that nene
leaks isn't on it
cause she used to just dominate
everybody she'd talk over all of them
and nobody seemed to have
enough game to be able to hang with her
so it got boring it was just like well
she's gonna win every argument
the [ __ ] am i watching this [ __ ] for
this is just like it's like groundhog
day
so um i like watching that one in the
real housewives of new jersey
now you're my [ __ ] father that [ __ ]
is just funny to me
um anyway but we watched this one
on um there was this guy
he married this woman and
uh they were together for like 20
25 years never had kids
and uh he meets some other chick she's
younger
he falls in love with her uh his wife
finds out
and she ends up killing the mistress
and then killed herself and
uh [ __ ] crazy story
and uh the husband tells the story and i
have to tell you this
me and my wife watch this and we were
just like i do not believe a
[ __ ] word that is coming out of this
guy's mouth
not a [ __ ] word the guy was like
i don't know it was like
he had he was he was basically doing the
show because he was promoting his
book and he was
in the re-enactments
you know with the part where he's like
he's now you know now that they're both
dead and gone he's packed up all of his
stuff and they're showing him driving
off in a convertible
like [ __ ] bill bixby at the end of
the hulk
and um i don't know i was just sitting
there going like
this guy i don't know i don't know but
there's just something it's just
and i noticed when i watched it like
the other chick his mistress also was
married
the husband of her wasn't on it
none of this guy's family members the
husband none of his family members were
there like this is how i you whenever
you have like those [ __ ] things
like when they'll be like they'll do
like a documentary
the true hollywood blah blah blah of
whatever famous person
um the second you don't see a bunch of
famous people in there talking about it
you're just like all right this is just
a bunch of trash
and they'll be like uh you know dick
cavett's mailman
you know dick's a really interesting guy
it's like who the [ __ ]
are you so yeah there was a lot of
people that i felt like
should have been in that documentary and
were not and it was just sort of him
and i kept calling him the nudger
because he had this way of like
he he would be sincere and then he would
just
float out a little bit of information so
it would be like so you do the math oh
well one plus one equals two he just he
wouldn't
tell you what to think but he'd nudge
you he was just like you know i was like
introverted and blah blah and then i met
her and she was like
outgoing and really like rebellious and
said whatever she wanted to say
and she complete opposite of me and you
know always had to get the last word in
her argument
and beautiful hair but but buried that
in the middle always had to get the last
word in the argument
and then you're like oh and that's why
she killed the day and then shot herself
so
he would have to live with the kill
while there there we go there when i i
you
and you and you think that you're the
one putting it together and then after a
while you're like wait a minute
wait a [ __ ] minute so i don't know
what the [ __ ] happened in that one i
actually had
a buddy of mine who's a lawyer who does
criminal [ __ ] i'm like
you know trials and stuff and can you
watch this thing and tell me what you
think and he goes
i mean i think that's kind of what
happened he kind of went along with it
i was like well he's on a book tour he's
doing dr oz and he goes
well you know he said the proceeds of
the book is going to charity i s
did he say a hundred percent let me just
say the proceeds
fine prints some of the proceeds i don't
know
um yeah me and nia we're gonna do we're
gonna start talking about those true
crime ones on the ones
we're going to do a news segment called
it doesn't add up
in the same way my unathletic ass breaks
down [ __ ] hockey and football games
now with no criminal justice degree or
any
anything no never was a you know former
cop or anything i'm gonna tell you
how the police officers got it wrong
which i think is a nice way to end the
podcast
considering i started out it off making
fun of people
who aren't doctors questioning doctors
and i am now
going to as a non-cop gonna tell you how
the cops got it wrong
i'm an idiot hey you know what the
feeling's coming back in my finger that
i cut off with that [ __ ] mandolin
i have not had a vegetable since you
know whatever i sliced up that day that
i didn't [ __ ] bleed on oh jesus bill
i was worried that i was gonna have a
numb finger
but it seems to be coming back i want to
thank the people that sewed it up
they did a great job um oh yeah it's all
coming back
nice nice nice baby
all right that's the uh thursday
afternoon podcast i hope you guys are uh
i'll be doing all right
and i hope all you youngsters out there
who are [ __ ] angry lunatics and you
relate to me
i hope one day you figure out why you
were angry and uh i'm not gonna divulge
you know it's too personal but uh it's
it's a
hell of a thing when you figure it out
because once you figure it out then you
kind of realize like
wow for my whole life i was kind of who
i wasn't supposed to be
is there is there enough time left in my
life
to go back to who i was supposed to be
which is [ __ ] that's pretty uh it's
pretty heavy man
um all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves have a great weekend you
[ __ ]
uh enjoy the music and we'll have a
bonus episode of the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast right after the music it's a
i guess the greatest hits one from uh
thursday a year ago or
i don't know how we work it out but um
that's what we got andrew for
all right speaking of which i'm gonna
[ __ ] text him so i can get those blue
glasses man
all right that's it i'll see you
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
um april 15th
2013. how are you how are you doing this
week
do you feel like this week is gonna be a
good one
um today's episode is brought to you by
ting please visit bill.ting.com
for a 25 service credit or device
discount
and i know what you're saying what is
ting well i'm gonna tell you later on in
the podcast
i'm building up advertising suspense
today's episode is brought to you by
cheerios what are those things again i
can't remember
sitting on the edge of my seat
the seat in my cubicle how are you guys
can you hear that can you hear that
[ __ ] engine running right now
do you know where your your lovely host
is
uh i'm on a [ __ ] bus man
i've been going through the south you
know they call it the dirty south and i
gotta tell you i haven't seen any filth
down here
other than a couple of no seriously
it's been an absolutely beautiful trip
and this time
old billy redface decided instead of
getting in a little ass [ __ ] car
and driving a [ __ ] thousand miles all
over the south as i toured around i
uh actually got a little bus here and
i've been on the road
with paul dude i called it verzi
and uh jason lawhead and uh we've been
doing shows
and uh drinking like the [ __ ] rat
pack
i think i've ever drank so much in my
[ __ ] life if you guys ever get a
chance to travel by bus
okay and i know you've all done it and
i'm not talking about that peter pan
greyhound [ __ ] right where you and 70
other people that you don't even [ __ ]
know
get on a goddamn bus right somebody
takes a [ __ ]
two feet away from you not talking about
that
i'm not talking about sleeping upright
the weight of your head waking you up
every time they go over a [ __ ] bump
i'm not talking about that either i'm
talking about getting your own bus
getting your own [ __ ] bus and
watching anchorman
drinking booze is somebody else drives
it's the greatest [ __ ] this is right now
i'm gonna tell you this and i'm going
right through it till wednesday this has
been the greatest
this is how big i'm going this has been
the greatest [ __ ] road trip
of my life um
this is perfect because you know what
gets you when you're out here people
it's not the shows oh no it's the travel
that's what [ __ ] beats you up when
you're an old [ __ ] like me
this is going to be a very full flight
people please don't put your coats in
the overhand compartments and then you
see the [ __ ] doing it
right we've oversold the flight
you know you [ __ ] land they don't
have your bags
you [ __ ] go out in the cab line it's
[ __ ] 90 000 people long
starts raining you put your shoulders up
to quote my own [ __ ] special right
you're standing out there with your
little stupid bag
middle of [ __ ] nowhere right you
finally get the cab
you can't understand the guy he can't
understand you you don't know if he's
going the long way
they tell it's a uh it's a flat fee
200 bucks to the hotel oh really i don't
think that's true
it's on the sticker read the sticker my
friend
right deal with that [ __ ] then you get
to the hotel the [ __ ] cab leaves
you bring your bag up hello sir welcome
to [ __ ] douche con hotel
do you have an idea and you give him the
id and then
could it be under another name you know
they can't find your [ __ ] room
then you finally get a [ __ ] room you
go to the hotel the [ __ ] up to the
goddamn we get it bill
now [ __ ] you i'm taking you through all
of it you get up there and the [ __ ]
key doesn't work you finally go back
down you get a key that works you go
back up it works you go in there
you know smells like jack klugman you're
like what the [ __ ] going on
you call downstairs do you have another
room this one smells like uh
archie bunker took a [ __ ] in here uh
no i'm sorry sir we don't have another
room and there's no reason to use that
language
oh yes there is
smells like somebody who smokes cigars
took his [ __ ] in here
and fought in korea all at the same time
all right well see when you get on a bus
all of that is over you know you pull in
you go to a walmart
you [ __ ] stock up the fridge with
food and booze
then you just get on the [ __ ] thing
and somebody else drives you
you sit there with your friends watching
anchorman getting you don't drink you
don't drink before the show
but after let me tell you something now
this thing's been great we just pulled
right up to the goddamn venue
you know there's a shower on the bus
right
you're good to go the other guys get
hotel rooms
i haven't been off this bus in [ __ ]
eight days and you know what i love it
i'm living in a bubble i don't even know
what the [ __ ] going on in the world
and furthermore i don't even give a [ __ ]
that's how much of a great mood i'm in
we pull right up to the venue
i get off the bus i walk into the venue
i do the show [ __ ] in a great mood
everybody has a good time
i then [ __ ] walk out front [ __ ]
myself out
show a little legs sell some dvds
smile and wave kiss a couple of babies
then i'll [ __ ] walk right back onto
the bus
and we leave town it's the [ __ ] and
then we start drinking
it's the greatest [ __ ] thing ever
so i gotta be i gotta be honest i don't
think this podcast is gonna be the
podcast i don't think it's gonna be so
too funny
because nothing bad happened to me
nothing bad happened to me this week
you know other than the fact
that this [ __ ] bus trip is gonna end
i got i got three more dates i'm gonna
be in tampa tonight for two shows then i
do florida state on tuesday and then
wednesday i'm in miami and then it's
over
and you know what then i have to go back
to the real world
a world where i have a dog with [ __ ]
up back feet
and i have a woman you know you know
i've been thinking this whole goddamn
week and nia is going to kill me but you
know something i wish i [ __ ]
you know could have done this like 10
years ago
15 years ago when i was single because i
got to tell you something
there's there is no easier way to bring
a bunch of [ __ ] out of a club
if you tell them you got your own bus
[Laughter]
oh god knows they love shiny [ __ ]
you have you have your own thing what
can i see it unfortunately you can't
sweetheart
um um speaking of horse oh
she's not a [ __ ] but i saw this story
right
where the [ __ ] is it oh no
really is it this is this gonna happen
is this gonna ruin my [ __ ] mood
why am i so dumb anyways there was this
giant
street party at rutgers right
and some pretty girl that just
didn't say pretty girl some pretty girl
when the cop showed up she uh she got
pepper sprayed
because she wouldn't put down her
frisbee that's what she said
not saying the old joke but seriously
that was her comment you know so then
you watch the video
and she's wearing this dumb neon hat and
you see her the first time the cops come
down the street she's giving him the
finger
and then doing the uh suck my dick
motion
[Laughter]
right there if i'm on the jury uh two
words
rightfully maced you can't do that you
could
why would you give the finger and in the
jerk-off move after you're standing next
to a burning couch
or had they not lit the was the couch
already on
fire it was insane it was like seven
[ __ ] houses
and all the parties were going on at
once and then they just sort of all met
out in the street looked like a
phenomenal party
but you know when the cops show up it's
over
you know you don't you don't start
[ __ ] kim
i got that that's one of those that's an
a classic [ __ ] chick move
i don't want to speak for all guys here
but i got to tell you right now one of
the last
things i would ever do is when a police
cruiser
is pulling up would be to be giving it
the finger not with one hand
both hands and then going like you know
acting like i'm jacking my dick onto
their [ __ ] car that is the last thing
probably the last move let's run through
the moves that you could possibly
[ __ ] make
that you could possibly [ __ ] make
when the cops show up
one the classic
turn the other way and begin walking
away
in a brisk manner that
doesn't draw too much attention to you
so it doesn't look like you're guilty
okay you just sort of casually turn
around
slip behind a couple people then crouch
down
and [ __ ] run as though you try not to
get hit by a sniper
disappear into the hedges there's always
hedges when you're outside partying
slip into the hedges crawl on your
[ __ ] elbows and knees
get to the backyard go over the fence
and just get the [ __ ] out of there
and ignore the people that stare at you
as you come over the fence with your
dirty knees and elbows
that's option number one
option number two is do the classic just
put your hands up like okay
all right we get it you're here it's
over
you know option number three
uh stand there very still and then
slowly do the side step
stop slowly do another side step stop
yeah i slowly get the [ __ ] out of there
you know what i'm saying where is uh
[ __ ] give the double finger and
jack your dick onto the cruiser
i guess you could do that too then you
run
right you don't [ __ ] stand there with
your frisbee
it's i don't know i've done this bit a
zillion times it's just a classic
just they don't know any better this
girl was beautiful
this girl has a vagina you know
a lot of you don't realize not all of
them not all women have vaginas
you know it's that lucky 99.9 percent of
them that have them
and she had them she had them she had
one and that was it she's standing there
what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
then of course they post it on youtube
or whatever on facebook and then it
becomes some sort of a [ __ ] story
this whole [ __ ] young generation of
kids it's so weird do you realize
they're like spying on themselves
i i wonder if any of them believe in
conspiracy theory they might they
they probably don't they got to be like
you know what
nobody's we're spying on each other
these [ __ ] [ __ ] every time they
do something they film it
they're sitting there filming they they
light a couch on fire which i don't know
what is that is that a misdemeanor i
don't know what it is
i know it's not i don't it's i know it's
not legal
i know it's not legal to light a couch
on fire and to be chatting
burn that [ __ ] burn that [ __ ] in the
[ __ ]
in the street see that's some [ __ ] when
i was younger
we would have done it but but we didn't
film it
not because we're smarter
because we you know what you had to do
to film [ __ ] when i was a kid
when i was of college age you know you
had a new somebody who [ __ ] knew had
real had to do that reel to reel [ __ ]
you knew how to splice and cut and put
the [ __ ] edit tape on you know like
you're making a beatles album it wasn't
worth it
dude when i was in college holy [ __ ]
that just freaked me out you know what
happened i just stood up
and accidentally in my bare feet here
stepped on the goddamn power pack thing
of the cord
and it was just warm enough to feel like
it was something that was alive like a
rodent i thought i just stepped on a
[ __ ] mouse
you ever have something like that
happening that caveman dna kicks in
that [ __ ] fight or flight is that a
saber-tooth tiger kind of thing right
um anyways this is the monday morning
podcast all right now ladies
i know you're beautiful i know you got
the jj's as [ __ ] oprah says all right
but do yourself a favor when the cops
show up don't give him the finger and
start jacking your non-existent dick
or maybe you do but if you do get the
[ __ ] out of there
and if you stand around and they're
coming up to you put your frisbee over
your face
you dumb [ __ ] oh my god i can't believe
i got
maced all i was doing was drinking
participating in the burning of a couch
in the street
the double finger was given to the
police officers and i
jerked a non-existent dick the dick
wasn't even there
i mean i could see if i actually had a
dick you know
and i pulled it out
your honor i don't have a penis how
could he bathe me
there's something hilarious about a
beautiful girl getting maced you know
at least there is to me there's just
always something funny about that [ __ ]
to me
like i'm saying this like i've seen
beautiful women get maced all the time
i haven't but i fantasized about it it's
just funny every once in a while when
they get treated like us
[Laughter]
welcome to the real world sweetheart yep
he did that and he's gonna get away with
it and there's nothing you can do about
it
all right so why don't you go upstairs
go rinse out your eyes with some tomato
soup or whatever the [ __ ] you're
supposed to do
actually tomato soup that's what you're
supposed to do when you when you get
sprayed by a skunk
i know that because i've watched a
couple of movies um
anyways what the [ __ ] am i doing here
let's get some advertising out of the
way so we can get back to the uh
podcast here e-voice everybody
all right e-voice are you trying to
you're trying to start your own business
all right are you are you stuck in a
soul-sucking job
and you have a great idea for a business
that's going to put you in the driver's
seat
all right rather than you sitting around
every six months to eight months to get
reviewed
to figure out how many more quarters an
hour they're going to give you you're
like you know what i want to be in the
driver's seat
if i want to work 12 hours a day i'm
going to do it for me
okay me i want to be in a position where
i can't be fired
because i'm not going to fire myself
that would be the weirdest way to kill
yourself
you know sort of some long drawn out
suicide you fire yourself from your own
company
you know and you don't give yourself any
sort of workman's comp
or unemployment
you become homeless walk around bitter
mad at yourself i'm sorry e-voice
everybody it's the reason you're gonna
make more money in 2013.
when your customers call you'll have
your own toll-free number professional
greeting dial by name directory and more
they'll just set it right up from day
one the second you sign up for this
you're going to sound like you have a
giant company
you sound like a fortune 500 company and
you'll blow away your competitors
e-voice lets you give out one number
that rings wherever you are
the beach the bar doesn't matter you'll
sound like you're at the office
isn't that wonderful in other words when
you're at your real day job
when that thing rings all you do is you
run into the bathroom then the echo of
the bathroom sounds like you're in your
giant office
um you've got to go to evoice.com and
use the promo code bill b-i-l-l e-voice
takes care of all your voicemails
transcribes them and sends them to you
instantly
as a text or email so you can check
voicemails before the meeting ends and
not look rude
e-voice is only 10 bucks a month 10
bucks a month to get your dream going
for a long time our listeners have been
able to get a free trial of e-voice for
six months
but this is about to come to an end all
right make sure
you sign up for the free trial of
e-voice between now and the end of the
month to get a six-month free trial
before it's too late please people go
after your dream
it's your last chance to try this great
service free
for six months six months for free get
your business going and after that
it's ten dollars a month there's nothing
i want more for you people
than to go after your dreams make them
happen
get on a bus and get some [ __ ] um that
last part is optional but don't get the
one in the green hat
if you do for the love of god keep her
inside for when the cops show up
um legalzoom.com everybody
all right look you got a plan for your
future all right this is all how to get
this
all the stuff that i'm selling you right
now this is how to get out of your damn
cubicle
all right evoice you got the whole uh
voicemail stuff now here you got
legalzoom.com
all right you got a plan for your future
you do financial planning you get
insurance
but to get real peace of mind you got to
make sure your family is legally
protected so where do you turn for
affordable
legal protection you can trust
legalzoom.com forever
for over 12 years excuse me they've been
helping americans
get personalized wills powers of
attorneys living trusts and real estate
documents and more
legalzoom also helps start and maintain
business with incorporation and llc
filings trademarks and copyrights
what a great thing if you're starting
your own business their time saving
service was
developed by a team of experienced
attorneys and legalzoom takes care of
you from stat to finish
legal zoom documents have been accepted
by courts and government agencies in all
50 states
okay legalzoom is not a law firm but
they can connect you to an attorney
and provide self-help services at your
specific direction for even more savings
and to bur in the referral box at
checkout
if you're a parent or an entrepreneur
don't wait any longer call or visit
legalzoom.com
and protect what's yours there you go
um something in there reminded me of
something oh i know i know
um we did the tabernacle theater
friday night um here in atlanta and i
got to tell you
the tavern i guess called yeah just
called the tabernacle
here in atlanta um right up there with
uh
carnegie hall one of the most beautiful
theaters i
ever performed in the crowd the crowds
were amazing
and um
jesus christ i'm sitting there thinking
how beautiful the theater is and i
literally forgot what the [ __ ] i was
talking about
i just had it what is that by the way
people what is that that thing where you
you [ __ ]
think about something to talk about then
you forget it then you remember it
and then you start talking and then you
[ __ ] forget it am i my the beginning
of alzheimer's here says this what it is
am i going to stop knowing people's
[ __ ] name that'll be the worst
well thanks bill thanks for letting us
know that alzheimer stinks because uh
without you we wouldn't have known that
all right go [ __ ] yourselves okay
it's not let's not ruin my good time the
[ __ ] did i want to talk about
what the [ __ ] happened in atlanta oh i
know i know
so we've been in atlanta for the last
couple of days
all right so a couple people go hey you
know we're going to cheetahs
strip club you want to go and i have not
been to a titty bar
and like [ __ ] ah [ __ ] why did i say
the name of it because now i'm gonna
trash the place
i haven't been to its titty bar in like
i would say
maybe seven years
i just stupid
you go in there you get all [ __ ]
excited and then nothing happens and
then you leave and you don't have any
money
it's the dumbest [ __ ] thing you could
ever do
there's always a bunch of fat white
dudes in there on some business trips
smoking cigars
trying to act like they're [ __ ]
running [ __ ] and they're not
i don't like them you know we'll figure
what the [ __ ] i'll go everybody's gonna
go hell let's [ __ ] go we went there
uh bored shitless
bored shitless you know what the most
exciting thing was about when i went to
that [ __ ] strip club
was one of the people i was hanging out
with i found out was actually uh a
banker
all right and i know you guys think i'm
out of my mind you're always going oh
you [ __ ] conspiracy theory
whack job i hit this guy with every
[ __ ] thing
that i think of i know about banks and
he just kept naughty going you're right
you're right absolutely you're right
i i [ __ ] told them that whole thing
about how you know i had the water
damage on my house and the check for my
insurance company came
made out to me nia and my [ __ ]
mortgage company
you know and i'm like those
[ __ ] don't think i'm gonna pay
off the house and they go no they don't
i go that's right they think that it's
gonna take me 30 [ __ ] years
and by the time that i'll be in my 70s
and by then one of my kidneys will fail
at which point my health insurance won't
kick in they'll have they'll so i'll
have to sell the house they'll get
another 30 year old in there and they'll
bend him over the [ __ ] rail for 60
and he was going you're absolutely right
absolutely [ __ ] right and i was like
so how do you [ __ ] do it he goes hey
he goes i don't [ __ ] over individuals
he goes i [ __ ] over businesses
[Laughter]
[Music]
see that's how it works you know
i wasn't making the i didn't i didn't
make the call i was just following
orders
it's the same [ __ ] those nazi
[ __ ] people said when they were up in
the guard towers
well they were fighting for [ __ ]
hitler it's exact same
[ __ ] thing they justified in their
head that
i'm not you know even though i'm part of
this evil [ __ ] thing
i'm just doing this one little thing
here you know
i just kept hammering i'm going dude you
know but you
you're part you're helping to push the
rock up the hill
and he goes and he just started laughing
going jesus christ you know i'm trying
to [ __ ] enjoy myself here and then i
actually felt bad on some level
i went all the way up to the federal
reserve and the guy the banker looked at
me he said the only thing
federal he said the federal reserve is
as federal as federal express
he goes they're evil and i was just like
well how the [ __ ] are you in that
business
you know and this one at that point
we're a little bit drunk and he's just
saying well what the [ __ ] am i supposed
to do
[Laughter]
he said the bankers just sit there and
they're like my job
is to make [ __ ] money that is my job
he proceeded to tell me that the bank he
works for
somehow in three months made six billion
dollars
he's like how is that [ __ ] possible
legally
i don't think it is or maybe it is
you know when everybody goes to work all
week and then just
gives you their money that's the
greatest that's one of the greatest
[ __ ] scams ever
do you realize we all work all [ __ ]
week
they give you a piece of paper with
numbers on it they never give you the
money
they just give you a piece of paper that
has numbers on it
then you take that piece of paper and
you give it to some of the most crooked
[ __ ] ever
to keep it safe
it's like it's like every american
everybody on the planet you get mugged
every week you don't even realize
you're not even getting mugged because
you're turning it over you [ __ ] hand
it to those [ __ ]
the money you earned the money i earned
then they take that money they loan it
back to us
it's [ __ ] interest and then they then
they like invent
more money that isn't even there off of
the money that we put in there they
basically they legally counterfeit money
like if they if
if they get a deposit at 10 grand they
can legally loan out 10 grand
thousand dollars to like what like four
or five different people
ten thousand for you ten thousand for
you ten for you ten for you
when there's only ten thousand they just
they just invented another thirty grand
that that isn't even there
and that's what the [ __ ] happens because
then when those [ __ ] don't pay that
off
the 10 grand all of a sudden that would
it now like
20 grand off of 10 grand isn't [ __ ]
paid off i i
think you guys are smart enough to do
the math
i i swear to god i really wish i
recorded the conversation when he just
kept going you're right you're right and
all the [ __ ] people
anthony kumar from the wonderful opium
anthony program
who laughs and shakes his head at me you
know
i was really wishing he was there and
every [ __ ] that ever called me a [ __ ]
conspiracy theorist
like i [ __ ] believe that the moon is
made out of cheese like that's what i'm
telling you
right like that i like i'm saying the
sun is actually a camera in the sky by
the [ __ ] illuminati i never said any
[ __ ] like that
all right i said a couple of crazy ones
my [ __ ] banker ones
evidently this guy who was drunk in a
titty bar
told me that i was right and none of you
guys were there
and i don't have the audio to prove it
but i'll go [ __ ] you you know what i
sound right this is like the verbal
version of that chick standing in the
street
i should have on the lime green hat just
[ __ ] miming jerking my own dick off
you know am i really any better than
that frisbee horde [ __ ]
ah she's not a [ __ ] she's not a [ __ ]
either
i don't you know what you know something
i'm going to reserve judgment because i
have no [ __ ] idea
you know when you really think about it
you really you really can't tell who
somebody is
just from a goddamn video all right shut
the [ __ ] up bill so anyways
i'm on this bus all week and uh me and
versi
in [ __ ] law had one night where the
hell were we coming from
well i'll give you the whole tour we
first of all we went to uh
we went to the uh the ncaa championship
game monday night
which was one of the sickest basketball
games i've ever seen in my life
uh we were in a football stadium
watching a basketball game um the game
eventually sold out
because a lot of people in atlanta a lot
of sports fans got upset with me
for uh describing 100 percent accurately
um their sports fandom
is that this the proper word um
seeing that dude luke come off the bench
and hit [ __ ] uh
three four three pointers in a row and
after three
that alley-oop jam was the sickest thing
that dude spike whatever
i'm not the biggest college hoop fan
spike whatever [ __ ] from michigan
you know what lawhead was joking about i
said in the he was joking like saying in
the first half
it was white dudes dominating the game
with outside shots of course god knows
when
our game has never been above the rim
white dudes were
dominating that game and then in the
second half black dudes just took it
over
and lie head was cracking us up saying
basically they were doing a reenactment
of basketball history i like the first
hack
half was like when [ __ ] uh bob cousy
you know back when you couldn't put your
hand on the side of the ball you had the
[ __ ]
you had to have it right on top of the
ball you ever watched that [ __ ] watch
all basketball highlights
and people always go like oh my god
these guys suck they didn't suck
if you put if you put your hand on the
side of the ball to go to the side that
was considered a carry
they've made all these [ __ ] rules
where uh which by the way have all been
great rules
you know to allow these athletes to read
the reach
the pinnacle of their their their uh
their sports artistry
i almost didn't get that out um
but it was just it was an unbelievable
game and there was this [ __ ]
louisville fan
sitting behind us and dude i gotta tell
you we were on the lower level and we
still needed binoculars
i'm not even gonna lie to you i mean it
was like
if we were at if we were at like an
atlanta falcons game we would have been
eighth row
in the end zone all right because we
literally could see the wall where they
would actually have like the
the post 911 people glaring at you
with their yellow coats on you know but
instead because it was basketball
there was there was like a fenced area
where you couldn't go past
and then there was a whole nother
section of about 20 rows
of these padded seats right and then in
front of that was a whole nother 20
section of just students and it was the
michigan kids
who by the way michigan used to be the
blue in maze
now it's just the maze um
i gotta tell you some of these [ __ ]
uniforms and some of this [ __ ] it's just
it's the loudest [ __ ] i've seen since
the 79 pirates
and uh considering that they're in the
midst of making anchorman part two
i think it's very i was actually
thinking
that you know they make you know they
make fun of the clothes from back then
in like the late 70s and everything when
they when they do the anchorman
of this this time right now
you know with sports and that's type of
thing if there's ever
somebody as big as a genius as will
farrell in like 20 years is making fun
of this era
it's going to be [ __ ] like that like
those uniforms when
michigan played syracuse i mean that was
just [ __ ] ridiculous those
yellow sneakers and the orange sneakers
that's
that's just something i'm gonna say
within maybe
four years well actually probably four
years it'll start to die off so i'll say
within 10 years you're gonna look back
at those things and be like jesus christ
the [ __ ] were we thinking um i saw a
couple of michigan fans with the old
school like
you know the blue where it says michigan
and yellow
it's funny as hell it looked like a
[ __ ] it looked like an
hd mustard and they were all chanting go
blue
it's like you guys don't have any
[ __ ] blue on anymore but i have to
tell you
we was so he was sitting on the michigan
side
and you know i flunked everything in
[ __ ] high school
and i used to sit there and try and
scare the [ __ ] out of me
you know going you need two years of the
language
you got to make sure your gpa is above a
3.6 so you're not going to get it but
you sat there and you're sitting there
[ __ ] nodding off just not giving a
[ __ ]
i got to tell you i went to that [ __ ]
basketball game
and the entire student section turned
around
faced us and like almost was doing like
this half tomahawk chalk thing
they went go and then everybody behind
us went
blue go blue the whole [ __ ] section
going nuts
and i said the [ __ ] version i said
you know my freshman in high school
year in high school instead of scaring
the [ __ ] out of me academically they
just should have showed me a video of
this going you know what if you actually
study in high school you can participate
in something like this and i would have
been like well you know what i'm going
to go home and hit the books
i would have done that instead of
telling me all the academic [ __ ] that i
need they should have showed me how fun
college could have been if i actually
studied
and went to a real [ __ ] school
you know i didn't i completely
i [ __ ] up my freshman year of high
school i went in there
and i was thinking i was going to be a
lawyer and i was going to go to notre
dame university
those were my goals by the time
sophomore year came around
i was looking at wentworth college and i
was considering
getting into construction
what a [ __ ] idiot now i go around all
these big schools you know i [ __ ] uh
go to these games
go like an lsu game or a georgia bulldog
game ohio state michigan you just go to
these [ __ ] things
and you just see these k i hope the kids
appreciate it
maybe that's what you know i think maybe
you have to be like me to really [ __ ]
appreciate how awesome it is
to go to a school that has such an
insane
[ __ ] sports program this is what i'm
jealous about those colleges kids
is that for the rest of their lives they
can kind of stay connected
to their college by following the teams
and if they ever want to have like a
mini
reunion with their tailgate friends you
just pick a game once a year and you go
to it and have a great [ __ ] time
you know oh jesus did i [ __ ] up
it's making me sad um
but you know what makes me happy
everybody never having to go to the post
office again
huh oh that was a nice segue stamps.com
everybody
you postage meter companies used to have
to uh
have the monopoly on printing postage
they could charge you an am and a leg to
print postage from your own office but
those days are over
now you can use stamps.com instead with
stamps.com
you can get all the benefits of a
postage meter but at the fraction of the
cost all you need to do
all you need is your computer printer
and stamps.com to get official u.s
postage for any letter or any package
any class of mail plus you'll never have
to set
step foot in the post office again um
everything you would need to do with the
post office you could do right from your
own desk
it's so convenient i don't know why you
wouldn't do it
if somebody as dumb as me can use
stamps.com
you know to send out my dvds to all my
wonderful shows
um look if i can figure it out so can
you so don't be intimidated
don't be an old fuddy daddy like me like
well i've always gone to the post office
and i still want to go
because it's comfortable step outside
your comfort zone
and improve your quality of life right
now use my last name burr burr for this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer includes a digital scale and
a 55 dollar free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur
b-u-r-r that's stamps.com enter bur
all right back to the podcast
don't save there we go where the hell am
i
all right let's uh let's get to reading
some of your questions for this week
um oh i didn't i never finished that
story
so we get done um we we go we did athens
the first night
down uh what is that it's northeast
of atlanta first day we went to the
basketball game the next day the tour
starts right now we have to go to work
pay for all the [ __ ] money we spent
the night before i don't think at the
end of this i don't think i made any
money but i had a great [ __ ] time
all right um my quarterly taxes are due
this is gonna be a rough one
somebody's gonna be eating froot loops
um
so we do athens georgia first
right and we're all [ __ ] giddy just
freaking out we do the gig
have a great time this beautiful theater
i really don't have any funny [ __ ]
stories because everything just worked
out this week
it was a tuesday night the place was
packed
um what happened on that show nothing we
just had a great time i did have to get
into
one guy one guy just kept screaming and
yelling he was too excited
so i went off on him and i ended it with
i'm ashamed of you
[Laughter]
which is quite possibly one of the
funniest things one grown man could say
to another one
i am ashamed of you um then we got off
we got on the bus because we were uh
we were driving up to uh oh did we stay
on the bus that night
no no no no we drove up to to hoover
alabama
oh all right now i can take you through
the week so we go up to hoover alabama
to play the stad dome
the next night we go up there [ __ ]
alabama by the way
absolutely beautiful [ __ ] state i
would retire i'm actually thinking about
retiring there
for the simple fact nobody [ __ ]
retires there
you've never heard that in your life
people retire where they go out west
everybody goes to [ __ ] arizona
right and out east everybody goes to
florida the midwest people
they they retire in the carolinas all
right
nobody [ __ ] retires nobody from
outside of alabama retires in alabama
hence you can get like 90 acres for
about 67
go out there get me a spread right
i don't know i couldn't get a direct
flight anywhere that would suck unless i
was going to mississippi
but who cares at that point i think that
that's what you do is you [ __ ] you go
to
really expensive [ __ ] places like new
york
la chicago and you bust your [ __ ] ass
your whole [ __ ] life
you make a bunch of goddamn money and
then in the end you retire
to a beautiful state that nobody wants
to go to for some stupid [ __ ] reason
and then all the all the uh assets
that you've accrued you sell those
things and they're worth three times as
much
down in [ __ ] alabama you just retire
there get yourself a giant [ __ ] dish
you get all the sports channels
it's not like they don't have food down
there you know and then pick a school
alabama or auburn
crimson tide a war eagle and enjoy
yourself
just a good old boy right so then we did
hoover alabama
and this is the best part right after
hoover alabama we had to be in columbia
south carolina the next night
which i've never been to so
it was one of those deals was the second
the show was over we got on the bus
and we just started driving and uh we
got a bottle of makers
and we just started pouring drinks we
popped in [ __ ] anchorman
watched that laughed our asses off
and uh
i don't know we just polished off the
bottle somewhere about four or five
hours into the [ __ ] trip
by the way we're supposed to be sleeping
we're supposed to be sleeping
and the bus driver who slept during the
day he's supposed to be up driving you
know
so we get about four hours into this
eight hour trip
and we pull the guy pulls over the bus
and he goes look uh
he's like we're gonna get there too
early you know for when we check in
at the hotels you know so we just
got to kind of chill here for a minute
sleep on the bus and we're like yeah
cool no worries so he goes just he goes
to bed
i'm going to bed he goes to bed
and we keep [ __ ] drinking somewhere
in the middle of that
me and versi get into this giant [ __ ]
new york
boston argument that i think went on for
like 40 [ __ ] minutes
it was hilarious absolutely hilarious
and then got real for like three minutes
and then got hilarious again uh
so [ __ ] stupid people from those two
cities will never get along
and then finally i don't know what
happened at like five in the morning i
was just like guys i got to go to bed
right version and [ __ ] lawhead yeah
no worries no worries right
so i [ __ ] go back in the back go to
bed
and uh evidently versey had just kept
going
the bus driver wakes up at like 8 30 in
the morning
comes from the back walks up to the
front of the bus opens the door
and he sees [ __ ] law head and verse
he still
still sitting there drinking and he goes
man you gotta be [ __ ] kidding me
and uh i'm not gonna name names or
anything like that but this bus driver
has seen a lot of [ __ ]
he's driven a lot of people so to get
this guy to be like
man you got to be [ __ ] me was was a
major [ __ ] accomplishment
uh i'll take you through the tour real
quick so then the next night we were
we drove into uh
columbia south carolina which is from
what i hear
just like savannah georgia except nasser
as the people there said
and um i don't know i got up around like
one o'clock two o'clock or some [ __ ]
and i just walked two miles from where
we parked the bus outside the hotel and
went down to the whole old area of uh
of south carolina columbia south
carolina it was [ __ ] insane
this is a place where like bankers
retire after they steal money for 60
years
they [ __ ] i was sitting there walking
down the street and um
there's some horse-drawn like carriage
thing that people are like taking a
tour of the area and all these old homes
the lady has the uh
the rebel confederate hat on minus the
flag right
and she's like if y'all look over there
that house is for sale for nine million
dollars
this old ass [ __ ] house that i'm
looking at like
probably 100 to 150 years older than my
house
this thing maybe is from the early 1800s
right
and uh if not the 1700s and i'm just
thinking of all the
[ __ ] that i've gone through with my
house
that's 90 years old and that's all i saw
i'm like you're gonna pay [ __ ] nine
million dollars for that really that's
what you're gonna do
and you're gonna be out [ __ ] you know
with the movies and a pipe is gonna
burst and you have to deal with that
bull
go [ __ ] yourself if you play nine
million dollars for a house you're an
[ __ ]
you're an [ __ ] all right
you're in banking that's what i would
guess you're either in banking
or you worked for insurance companies
and collected premiums and then when
people's [ __ ] gallbladders
bursted you didn't give them the [ __ ]
money either did that
or you invented the flow b other than
that i don't know how
you either just straight up steal [ __ ]
legally or you [ __ ] uh
you come up with just some dumb [ __ ] the
jack chop
right some sort of thing to chop up
lettuce
you know or make fat people more
comfortable that's another one right
all right here we go um in limbo hey
bill i'm 22 years old from the suburbs
long guy land the youngest of four and i
guess you could say
i'm the black sheep of the family i
didn't go to college
after high school mainly because i had
no clue what i wanted to do
and i didn't see how spending three
grand at a shitty community college
would help me figure that out
three grand dude see now that's where
you want to go to college where it's
three grand
you come out of there you're not
swimming in debt but you have no team to
follow
um anyways however i'm a dc musician and
have acted
in a friend's student films and people
told me i'm somewhat talented in that
area
for the past years or so i've become
clinically depressed
i feel that there isn't much left for me
here and i'm sick of my friends
i was thinking about moving to la with
the friend and his brother i'm hoping i
can find
some things out there and just mainly to
get away from the life i have now
also looking forward to all the low
self-esteem
struggling actress ass i've heard so
much about
um however over the that last year or so
my relationship with my family has
not been going so well should i stick
around and work on my life here
and put the pieces back together or go
out there and meet some new people and
have some new experiences
yeah [ __ ] come out to la or wherever
the hell you want to go
i think you're depressed because you're
in a circle of people that are all
following the same [ __ ] lead
buffalo over over that cliff all right
you're still going to go over a cliff as
we all do but you want to be following a
buffalo that's going in the [ __ ]
direction you want to go to
oh my god he's using animals as a
metaphor
um sir i would say i
i mean if you're clinically depressed i
mean i don't know if you have something
[ __ ] like uh
like you know chemically going on i
can't help you with that but if you're
just [ __ ] depressed
because you know doing what all your
friends and family is doing
and it's just soul sucking every goddamn
day
i can help you with that all right if
you're clinically [ __ ] depressed i
mean you need to see a doctor or some
[ __ ]
you know i don't know see what sort of
witchcraft he can offer you but if
you're just [ __ ] depressed i mean i
would definitely
uh go for a change of scenery
um but i would also say if you're
stepping into the
to a life of the arts like you you
really you have to have a game plan
the same way somebody who's gonna become
a banker does
like a banker goes okay um
i'm gonna join this evil business and
i'm gonna make as much [ __ ] money as
i possibly can
and if i have to make old people who
actually fought
for this country have to eat alpo for
the rest of their [ __ ] lives because
we're gonna rape and pillage their 401ks
this is these are the steps i need to do
one
shut off all feelings for other human
beings you know they make a list
[Laughter]
justify my evil by saying i'm a small
part of the bigger evil
but my evil is actually a very low level
of evil amongst the
ridiculous level of evil um
no like as far as what i did
um when i became a comedian was i just
they were just very small steps
one sit down and write jokes two sign up
for open mic
three have the balls to go up there when
they call your name
four no matter how bad
or good it goes sign up for another open
mic
and just i just kept i just kept you
know
you kind of if you look too far down the
[ __ ] road it's going to become
overwhelming
when you're when you're going after
something like that you just handle what
you can handle that day
and um i i would do that i can tell you
that if you're going to just start
being a stand-up comedian la is a really
hard place to start
you kind of want to have your act
together and have a little bit of
momentum when you go out there
um but if you want to act
and be an actor i mean there's that's
where there's a ton of work but
um you know i don't know when you're
going to go out to la but i'm sure
wherever you live at there's there's
some sort of place where you can start
taking acting classes
which is probably what i would do
you know
look if you just need to change the
scenery and you want to go out in the
fun in the sun and go
live down on the beach um los angeles
and greater los
angeles like south of there and
everything is one of the great places
you could ever live in your life i know
there's a ton of traffic but still
some of the most beautiful women you're
ever gonna see you know if you get
outside of l.a most of them aren't even
in the business so now they're just a
beautiful woman on a beach you know
and if that doesn't pick up your spirits
i don't know what will
but um you know if you seriously want to
become an actor and that type of thing i
wherever you're at i would start taking
some acting classes
to see if you actually do have a knack
for it slash
if you have a passion for it do you go
down there you start acting and then
that makes you want to read some plays
or makes you want to go re-watch some
movies to learn
if you if you get like the bug you know
and you really feel like this is
something you want to pursue
um then i would work my ass off on that
when you
when i felt like i had my act together
and i maybe done a play or two
uh go out to la get yourself a [ __ ]
agent or
and welcome to this [ __ ] up business
like i've always said if a jackass like
me can get anywhere so can you
um all right next one uh follow up to
last week's miserable law student and
some
ass kissing all right well i'm going to
go blow past the [ __ ] ass kick
kissing we'll read a follow-up bill
first off i'm sorry about the length of
this email
i know you are busy look you don't have
to sugarcoat it you just write bill
sorry about the length of this email i
know you suck at reading out loud
anyways i am a lawyer and this is just
how i write and think
i implore you to take 10 minutes to read
it
you know what when anybody uses the word
implore and just because you said you're
a lawyer i just pictured you
you you're speaking to the jury and you
just clapped both your hands together
like clashed them together
i implore you to look at the evidence
uh whatever that i am generally thinking
you were thinking thanking you for being
a good man
if you want to use some of it or all of
it feel free if not
then no hard feelings i promise not to
show up
to your house and money more all right
okay last week you read a letter from a
kid who finished his first year of law
school who was trying to decide whether
to drop out
he noted that he hated law law school
and was unhappy
you told him to walk away speaking as an
attorney with 10 years 100 trials
murders rapers you name it
please let me say this your advice was
spot on
oh my god i thought you were going to go
the other way i know you're gonna be
like listen law school is terrible but
once you get out of it and get into the
exciting world of sitting next to a
rapist who you know did it but for some
reason you have to defend him
um it makes it all worthwhile
um in my line of work we use the term
jaded
jaded is the state uh where an attorney
no longer gives a [ __ ] about his clients
he simply does his job out of obligation
and the need to bring in a paycheck
dude how the [ __ ] can you be in that
mindset
when somebody's freedom is on the line
dude i swear to god life is so [ __ ]
scary once again
one of the dumber things i've said
nothing will ever be dumber than when i
was on joe rogan's podcast
and i whatever the [ __ ] i said about
science like
science is like fascinating
it's neat i said something really stupid
like that
science is like amazing um listen listen
to the joe rogan experience by the way
uh or reach out to one of his listeners
i'm sure they can tell you where it is
in that podcast where i said it it's
really it was so dumb i wasn't even
embarrassed
i almost felt like uh i felt freedom
you know almost like i was like someone
if they come out of the closet
you know i was coming out of the closet
of stupidity i was tired
of pretending to be this person that i
wasn't
[Laughter]
is he in the closet stupid or is he out
of the cleaves out of the closet
he announced to the world he like that
ellen remember that yep i'm gay i was
that i should have been on the cover of
time magazine yep
i'm stupid right shrugging [ __ ]
little
mixer in front of me as i record the
podcast all right bill we get it
okay i have 15 cases tomorrow this
lawyer says
each of which is a human being facing
prison
some for decades the truth is that i
don't give a [ __ ] about a single one
oh my god i'll do my job but be it via
the path of least resistance
i just want to get back to my office and
check latimes.com
i should probably offer some excuse but
i won't truth is that every criminal
defense attorney
gets this way within three years of
passing the bar
wow are you just speaking for yourself
and thinking it's everybody are you
serious
oh my god god help me if i ever have to
[ __ ] go to
get a defense attorney jesus christ
anyways between my first and second
years of law school
i learned that i love commercial
aviation
oh so here it is so no dude you can't
tell you can't say all lawyers are like
this
you want to be a pilot right
wait a second he says not flying but
rather the aircraft itself
i love every little nook and cranny
every little screw and spring
but i ignored my passion and pressed
forward instead of following a dream and
moving to seattle where boeing is based
i took a big paycheck as a public
defender every day
now i look in the mirror and wonder what
could have been all right wait a minute
okay so you well then you can't lump all
attorneys because some people it's their
dream to be an attorney
and they want to go there and they want
to do something well i know i know a
couple of great attorneys
i have a great attorney the guy's a
[ __ ] animal
he's up there prowling the stage killing
the crowd but doing it in a legal
in the legal field ah dude this kills
this this [ __ ] kills me
in all on all series this kills me like
nothing else
hearing stories of people wanting to do
other things and then not doing it dude
what's to stop you from quitting right
now and just doing it
it's not like you're 80. anyways between
my first and second years of law school
i learned that i love commercial i
already read that part sorry
um the sad truth is that the law student
who emailed you
will not listen to your advice he'll
finish now that's not true sir let's not
superimpose your life but okay
he'll finish law school since he's
already committed if you ever get the
chance
tell him that after he ignores you he
does not need to practice law
a law degree opens a ton of doors but
the minute you take the bar you commit
yourself to a life
of pain and unhappiness i'm not kidding
of the hundred plus lawyers i know not a
single one likes their work
every one of them will tell you not to
go to law school
walk away from the bar go become a
broker
go teach at a jc junior college go work
for a business
open a spear fishing business in bali
whatever just don't go and take the
bar there are two reasons i'm writing
you today the second
that i want to commend you and say that
you are not a [ __ ]
um you speak your mind using language
you choose you followed your close path
and have made the sacrifices necessary
to later reap the rewards
but more than that you have integrity
and honor and for that i thank you jesus
dude don't put me on that pedestal i'm a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
um and i have regrets too
i'll wake up the middle of the night and
start screaming like ron burgundy
trying to [ __ ] get those thoughts of
regret out of my head
we all have regrets sir and it's not too
late for you to move to [ __ ] seattle
you know what's stopping you from moving
to seattle one conversation with the
[ __ ] people you work with
and a couple of suitcases that need to
be filled
that's it who gives a [ __ ]
i'll tell you dude if you you should you
should follow your heart man and it's
not too late and i don't give a [ __ ] if
you got a kids and you're married
move them right just move them up there
save up some money
[ __ ] move up there live a little more
modest it's a beautiful part of the
country
and uh you know your kids will watch
they'll see somebody pursuing a dream
you'll be in a better mood you'll be a
better husband and father if you're
married
all right if you're single you got no
[ __ ] excuse
all right pack up all your three-piece
matlock suits
and go to seattle anyways a few months
back a listener wrote
about how his girlfriend was upset
because he went to a strip club and put
oil on a woman's tits
your response was telling your advice
was to reverse the situation in his mind
then apologize it was brilliant it was
the advice that one man gives to another
i could come up with countless examples
but they'd all be saying the same thing
you tell your listeners to be fair and
honest with their women
do i i always think i come off as a
misogynistic douchebag dear
you tell the sad and depressed to try to
get out and then seek help if
unable you tell your young to save their
money and you tell people not to use
drugs but for legitimate reasons
um i could go on and on but i'd be
repeating the point sad point is that
your podcast demonstrates
what it is to be a good man jesus christ
i wish neil was listening to this [ __ ]
she'd be laughing her ass off i
appreciate this he said you sir a good
man
never let that voice in your head tell
you otherwise well listen
you uh i don't know it's killing me that
you that people
like yourself you're acting
like you're acting like wherever you
live
between you and seattle like you're in
you're behind you know the old [ __ ]
eastern bloc
and there's a bunch of guard towers you
know
and there's some sort of war zone
between you and seattle there isn't
you know sir you could actually practice
law in seattle
you know if you just wanted to make
money on the side
you know just get this listen
sit down tonight and figure out a
[ __ ] way to get your ass to seattle
and i guarantee you when you sit down
and you start writing it out your game
plan
you're gonna feel the excitement that
you that you're missing
being a lawyer and being a lawyer is not
a bad job it's just not what you were
supposed to do
okay because i guarantee you the same
way you look at an airplane and you love
every screw every spring every nook and
cranny of an aircraft
there's lawyers who they love the smell
of a courtroom they love that big wooden
[ __ ] desk they love the closing
argument they love that moment the turn
you know whatever
you're just [ __ ] flipping around on
the other guy
you know they love defending they love
prosecuting they love the [ __ ] sound
of their shoes walking across the
courtroom
they love it they [ __ ] love it
you do not love it so my advice to you
is
um get your [ __ ] ass to seattle
all right jesus christ who gives
what are you worried about sir you're
not going to have you're not going to
have uh
what are you not going to have flat
screen tv doesn't cost [ __ ] now you'll
have enough
dude as long as you're willing to make
the [ __ ] sacrifice you can make it
happen all right
what's the matter what are you waiting
on you know oh oh i have to eat [ __ ]
grape nuts every day who gives a [ __ ]
you know peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches for for lunch who gives a
[ __ ]
you know watch this thing on 60 minutes
about [ __ ] boy
soldiers people kids getting kidnapped
turned into murderers
you know don't even have a [ __ ]
childhood they get sucked right into
fighting a goddamn war
following this goddamn basically the
closest thing to a zombie
i've ever seen in my life and their
whole lives get [ __ ] ruined
you know you're a lawyer in a free
country who wants to move to seattle
don't [ __ ] disappoint me you better
write me back and tell me you're in
seattle
all right but please for the love of god
don't ever become a jaded pilot
[Laughter]
oh my god i'm so [ __ ] bored with
flying i just have this feeling that
i just want to push the [ __ ] was it
the yolk whatever the [ __ ] that goddamn
stick sometimes i feel like i just want
to push it forward
um crazy x billiam catching up on the
podcast
and you just told a story about a woman
you used to date that threatened to kill
you and then made a tin of brownies
now she said she was going to stab me
she didn't say
fatally um that's where you ended the
story
dude how did you finally get rid of her
in case you're wondering yes
my life is that dull that i actually
give a [ __ ] how the story ends
um no i did kind of leave you hanging
how did i get rid of her
um i was really young and naive and this
is what she would do she would call me
up and i would pick up the phone
this is before caller id and [ __ ] so i
picked the phone up it would be her and
then i would be listen i don't want to
talk to you and then she'd start crying
and i was an idiot because i thought she
was crying legitimately i didn't realize
that it was a
manipulation tactic to make me feel bad
and make me feel like i'm a [ __ ]
bully so i'd stay on the phone
talk her down and be nice to her where
she wasn't crying anymore and then we
would end
with a nice ending to the phone
conversation but in her
psycho stalker world that meant that we
were somehow still connected
and back together and then she would
call me again and i would say listen i
don't want to talk to you then she'd
start crying it was this [ __ ]
circle i that i couldn't get out of
cycle i should say um
it was funny ever since dan cook's
vicious circle came out i never say
vicious cycle anymore
it was a it was a cycle i could not get
out of
um so finally my manager at the time
just says listen
because i said what the [ __ ] do i do he
goes listen when she calls
you pick up the phone if it's her just
hang up
just hang up and that's what i just
started doing i would pick up the phone
and she'd be like billy and i would just
click i just [ __ ]
i just hang up and uh
within 10 days she stopped [ __ ]
calling me
i mean granted at that point i was
living on the other side of the country
for half of the [ __ ] time but i just
kept
i just kept hanging up and um
i did have the advantage like i said of
not still being in the same city
but what you have to do is if you have a
girl like that is you just
or a guy well a guy is different i
really feel bad for women when it comes
to [ __ ] like that because guys
um you know
i guess there are women out there that
actually take it to some ridiculous
violent level but obviously guys do it
more often
but i'm so this is my advice for guys if
you have some crazy lady
in your [ __ ] life that's what you do
you just gotta you can't give him
anything because people like that
you give him one little [ __ ] ray of
light they latch onto that and they
think you guys are getting [ __ ]
married or some [ __ ]
um all right
that's the crazy x that's how it ended i
just stopped [ __ ]
it's not really exciting i just kept
[ __ ] hanging up on her and eventually
she went away and every once in a while
uh she would try to [ __ ] reach back
out and i just just no just nothing
beat it leave me alone
i think she reached out and tried to
friend me on myspace a long time ago i
just did not accept it and then that's
the last i ever heard of her that's how
you do it
all right cancer lady question morning
bill big fan
go [ __ ] yourself i've got myself into an
inevitable situation
and now need some advice on how to get
myself out of it a few months back
i started seeing this girl who a few
weeks in found out
she could potentially have cancer oh
geez
jesus dude wow i wasn't
into that i wasn't that into this girl
to begin with
but figured i'd have some fun and when
the time came to end it i would
but after she told me about the possible
cancer diagnosis i felt bad for wanting
to end it
so like an idiot i stuck around ah jesus
like if you're young i can't fault you
for that
you know you now you think you're
[ __ ] doing her you're doing her a
favor you're actually making it worse
oh oh my god dude i'm getting like deuce
chills how do you get out of this
oh because no matter what it's going to
make it seem like you left because she
had cancer anyways a few months have
passed
and the cancer scare is over but now i'm
stuck in this situation no you're not
that's your green light
[ __ ] screen doors open run out of
there needless to
say she's a lot more into this
relationship than i am and
i just want out and away from her maniac
kids asap dude i bet you
[ __ ] dimes the dollar there was no
cancer [ __ ] scare i bet she did that
to suck you into the [ __ ]
relationship
i saw a thing on tv the other day and
you know god knows if you see it on tv
it's got to be true
some woman did that told everybody that
she was dying of cancer including her
[ __ ]
boyfriend the [ __ ] had went ahead and
married her
idiot anyways he said is there a smooth
way out of this [ __ ] without
making it obvious
that i only stuck around because of the
cancer is there a good exit strategy
thanks for the help and come to toronto
soon [ __ ]
um there's no smooth way out of a
[ __ ] relationship
there isn't you just have to sit down
and say listen we need to talk
and then they go okay and you say listen
i'm not happy
i'm not happy i think you're a great
person and everything but i'm just not
feeling
like you're the one boom right there
what did that take eight seconds to say
that
you just say it you just say it just say
it and just get
it out there and then let the [ __ ]
chips fall
she's gonna cry she might scream she
might throw [ __ ] at ya
you know neighbors will be peeking
through their curtains
but just say that okay
she might try to get you to [ __ ] go
back in you know manipulate well
maybe we could work it out would you
want to talk to somebody
maybe we could talk to somebody about it
i'm
i no i just this is truly what i'm
feeling and it isn't fair
to you for me to continue sticking
around it's just preventing you from
meeting the person you're supposed to be
with
and myself also i'm sorry i feel
horrible but
i have to be honest with you and you
can't [ __ ] with that
and then you're out i mean no you're not
out you got to sit through another 180
minutes
of [ __ ] history onyx and everything
but but you're out okay
and you just sit down and you tell
yourself sir that you know what today at
two o'clock in the afternoon
i'm talking to my girlfriend soon to be
my ex-girlfriend and you know what
from two o'clock to five o'clock is
gonna suck [ __ ] donkey
[ __ ] balls all right but 501 on
is gonna be great all right this is like
you're a [ __ ] junkie i saw that on uh
uh dr um one of those [ __ ] doctor
shows
the [ __ ] is it i can't remember [ __ ]
anymore he was basically talking about
how addicts
will go through [ __ ] eight nine ten
years of hell because they don't want to
go through ten days
of uh of detox rather than dealing with
ten days of [ __ ] wretching and
vomiting and feeling like you're [ __ ]
you're like your
fingernails hurt 10 days of that you're
going to go through 10 days of hell and
be living out on a [ __ ] street just
to avoid those 10 days
of [ __ ] withdrawals that's what
you're doing if you stay in a [ __ ]
relationship you don't want to be in
all right just get the [ __ ] out
get out now and make me proud all right
dilemma dear bill your monday morning
podcast
has become religion over the past five
weeks
i came to see at the pabst theater in
milwaukee a year ago or so
and have been a fan ever since i just
thought i might bring to your attention
a question to my roommates and i
disagree
upon completely um in a fight to the
death
against an opponent of equal size
strength and skill
which weapon would you rather have on
your side a 20 ounce hammer
with a nail nail removing hook on the
end
or a 28 ounce wooden louisville
slugger the question is that's not even
it's a joke the question is which is the
better weapon
and your opponent is essentially you the
[ __ ] louisville slugger
without a [ __ ] doubt the louisville
slugger i can get you from a distance
what the [ __ ] you gonna do with your
hammer
you got a hammer you gotta get inside
unless you're gonna throw it at me and i
gotta bat i'll [ __ ] hit it right back
at you
i'll hit it over your head now you have
no [ __ ] weapon and now i'm coming
right doing that [ __ ] over under over
under right in front of my face
i i could dude i could literally have
that thing okay i bet i bet [ __ ]
right-handed
there the secret's over you now know my
stats throws right
bats [ __ ] right um
drums right plays guitar lefty right's
lefty i'm all over the [ __ ] map
so i [ __ ] i'd have it in my left hand
my my front hand like if i was up at bat
and i would come in do a couple step in
step out step in step out and then i
just [ __ ] whack you in your shin
and as you did that stupid little hop
i'm coming up top now
i'm first i'm doing short quick ones
real quick [ __ ] you up so you can't
so you know so you don't catch the bat
and then as you really start getting
[ __ ] up then i'm there now i'm going
for a double
then i'm going up the [ __ ] goddamn
warning track and then that's it
and i'm swinging for a home run and
you're [ __ ] done
split your head like a [ __ ] melon
[ __ ] you and your hammer
it's over um
whoever's picking the hammer is is
thinking like what would i rather get
hit with once with a bat or once with a
hammer
hammer's made out of metal bats made out
of wood
what's the stronger [ __ ] material
obviously a goddamn
hammer right metal all right but what
they're not thinking about is the
distance
you know what once you why don't you
email weren't you calling the joe rogan
podcast
joe rogan experience he'd be able to
break that down
all right people you know what that's a
podcast for this week
you